on three okay one tell me when I'm ready
so what do you think green wire hmm read
my mind
wait we don't know I am in charge
proceed my dear I have been trained in
mouth-to-mouth resuscitative measures
jeez by taste decisions in family right
she's got great taste I trust her
well what does she like with grassley
sweet bushes by the windows leads to new
curtains leads to new sofa we've seen
carpet lease new floor with baby dude
she's pregnant
how far along as you get over the boy or
girl she's not pregnant she's just
bought a weird journey moving through
the house one room to the next
I was expensive it sounds pregnant
high-pitched scream and you push my
sister in the web app was just sister
out of harm's way you shine the light in
those James you know it's different
strokes for different folks man with the
ice pack in his mouth no on his head
don't put that ice pack of my hair babe
I'm sensitive to extreme measures of
cold and you know that you put it on
your head cuz you just got knocked out
by yourself James you know what you
um guys maybe we should
is he still staring make him stop